aujourd'hui je vous emmène avec moi dans
un hôtel particulier dans une agence
c'est la chance presse de samsung pour
vous parler de cette jolie petite bête
c'est le galaxy fold qu'on peut même
ouvrir une main très pratique très sympa
vous allez voir le truc est juste
hallucinant
[Musique]
est ce que ça vous parle
certainement que je vous en parle on
parle beaucoup des smartphones je
m'étais la boit savamment qu'on parle
des smartphones à écran pliable jeu
s'est beaucoup parlé de rumeur de ce
cahier de ses smartphones en a parlé
dans une précédente vidéo et aujourd'hui
il est là il est beau il est chaud je
présente le galaxy fold alors ça c'est
un smartphone qui est hyper intéressant
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'il va
changer la donne il va apporter une
vraie évolution révolution en tout cas
dans l'univers du smartphone
c'est vraiment le point à retenir parce
que le form factor change complètement
c'est à dire que vous passez d'un
smartphone je dirais un peu d'embarras
smartphones qui marche bien avec des
grands écrans des caméras toujours
meilleur un format qui est complètement
différent qui va vraiment révolutionné
alors l'idée de ceux de ce galaxy folle
c'est effectivement que lorsque vous
louerez vous avez un vrai effet ou avec
un smartphone qui est juste énorme un
écran de 5,3 pouces c'est du pin oled
c'est vraiment très impressionnant je
vais vous montrer pourquoi alors avant
de rentrer un peu dans le détail il vous
montrez vraiment ce qu'on peut faire et
ce qu'on peut ressentir lorsqu'on à ce
smartphone en main c'est vraiment déjà
vous vous montrez un peu le design
[Musique]
ce qui pourrait surprendre au premier
abord c'est de se dire qu'on a un tout
petit écran ici sur la face avant ça
l'écran de 4,6 alors en réalité ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que ce petit écran la
sépare en réalité un écran de smartphone
alors je sais c'est un écran smartphone
on va pas se mentir j'ai la lune c'est
un smartphone et un écran de smartphone
mais en fait c'est un écran d'appoint
c'est juste plat pour visionner quelque
chose lorsque vous êtes dans les
transports en commun par exemple le vrai
écran se situe à l'intérieur c'est celui
là c'est du pin oled cdu 7,3 pousse
alors ici beaucoup de reflets donc là ça
nous fait un énorme écran qu'on peut
vraiment utilisé comme on veut on
retrouve avec nos applications bien
évidemment ce qui coûte par exemple
c'est lorsque vous allez allez sur maps
vers une vue qui est vraiment beaucoup
plus grande vu beaucoup plus immersive
et rien que pour ça c'est franchement
hyper intéressant plus voyez on est en
pile poil dans l'actualité mais ça c'est
une autre histoire
donc ça c'est vraiment intéressant
lorsque vous voulez vous rentrez plus en
immersion lorsque vous allez jouer aux
jeux vidéo la sensation d'immersion est
complètement fou regardez-moi ça cet
écran c'est juste hallucinant on a un
vrai confort qu'on n'aurait pas hop
autrement sur un smartphone un peu plus
ce temps là en profite vraiment d'un
énorme écran et c'est vraiment là dedans
que réside tout l'intérêt de ce produit
c'est d'avoir un truc hyper immersif
hyper grand très très grand écran
regardez si je vous mets à côté un autre
smartphone ça n'a strictement rien à
voir en terme d'immersion en terme de
jeu en termes de confort visuel
c'est juste génial de la même manière je
vais aller me regarder une vidéo par
exemple sur youtube
allez pas hasard fait vous recherchez un
youtube heures ce sera aller au hasard
monsieur greu ne serait-ce que le
confort la navigation lorsque vous aller
naviguer lorsque vous allez regarder sur
youtube comme ça pour choisir vos vidéos
c'est vraiment énorme et c'est vraiment
ça qui est vraiment hyper intéressant
avec ce format d'écran cède 3 pouces
ratio qui est complètement différent ça
change vraiment la donne c'est vraiment
hyper intéressant on va se mettre une
vidéo et c'est quand même vachement plus
agréable pour les regarder du contenu
alors je peux venir
est-ce que je peux nous mêlons pas
première journée le seul truc qu'on peut
être éventuellement venir reprocher
c'est la présence de cette petite
encoche sur le côté qui va venir vous
croquer un petit peu l'image venir
manger un petit peu dans l'image
bon d'accord c'est pas bien grave mais
c'est vrai que c'est vachement plus
grand c'est vachement plus immersif et
beaucoup plus agréable de ce point de
vue là ce format d'image est vraiment
vraiment hyper intéressant vous
retrouver sur le côté ici tout votre
multitâche
vous allez pouvoir disposer comme vous
le souhaitez peut naviguer sur internet
je peux faire ce que je veux comme je
veux ça c'est aussi vraiment tout
l'intérêt d'avoir un
une énorme form factor comme ça c'est
vraiment cool en termes de prise en main
tout simplement pour le plier comme ça
vers des hommes
il vient vraiment but est donc on n'a
pas un truc qui au final a mal fini
c'est vraiment bien fini fort mal cool
explique homs alors il faut vraiment
voir cet écran je vous dis comme un
écran d'appoint on est là pour voir ces
notifications converser sms pour pouvoir
faire un bon truc mais guère plus vous
avez à l'arrière trois caméras sont les
caméras que vous retrouvez sur le
samsung galaxy s 10 plus vous avez
absolument aucun logo aussi pas de
branding samsung vous retrouver
uniquement sur le côté et lorsque vous
ouvrez votre smartphone le branding
disparaît sur la face avant c'est pareil
absolument rien du tout ici vous allez
mettre votre carte sim
il n'y a pas de carte micro sd pas
l'extension par contre on a 500 12 giga
en natif dans le smartphone au goût de
ce point de vue là franchement il ya de
quoi faire bouton de volume
ici sur le côté sur la tranche bouton
bixby compas signé en bouton on/off si
on le souhaite
ici le capteur d'empreintes digitales
qui très très bien placé pour l'allumer
pour les tags comme vous le voulez ça
c'est cool sur le haut vous avez un haut
parleur ici en bas haut parleurs ici
pour le sensation plus d'immersion
lorsque vous jouez vous allez regarder
des vidéos donc ça c'est aussi ça marche
très très bien pour les maîtres comme ça
de ce point de vue là vous n'avez
absolument pas les obstruer parce que si
vous les mettez sur le bas vous tenez
comme ça vous allez les obstruer est là
pour écouter du son c'est tout de suite
un petit peu plus compliqué petit micro
ici vous avez le micro de réduction de
bruit qui situent juste là les antennes
de tous les côtés et asmar tincques été
testé deux cent mille fois en ouverture
et fermeture autant dire que vous pouvez
y aller vous allez le garder quelques
bonnes années avant d'avoir le moins de
problèmes alors du point de vue de la
caméra
vous allez retrouver à l'arrière
industrie grand-angle de 16 mégapixels
avec une ouverture de f 2.2 un
grand-angle de 12 mégapixels avec une
ouverture variable de f 1.5 à f 2.4 vous
allez avoir un zoom optique x 12 12
mégapixels une ouverture de f 2.4 à
l'avant vous avez une caméra selphy
d'appoint qui se situe juste là 10
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.2
et à l'intérieur vous avez ici deux
petites caméras qui sont planqués juste
la dînée gars pixels ouverture de f 2.2
8 mégapixels ouverture de f
1.9 et vous avez intérieur une batterie
de 4000 380 millions terreur avec de la
recharge rapide en usb type c
[Musique]
on pourrait éventuellement se dire
puisque je vous dis y'a pas longtemps
sur ce smartphone vous avez cette espèce
dans koch qui est l'art pourrait dire
ouais ouais c'est un peu dommage ça
serait mieux d'avoir une petite bulle
comme vous avez notamment sur un galaxy
s 10 plus alors oui dans l'absolu je
suis le premier à me dire ma c'est un
petit peu dommage
après ce qu'il faut vraiment voir si
vous avez quand même huit ans devait
réduire en sortir un produit comme ça à
trouver vraiment le bon enfant pour
hector trouver la solution qui marche
alors on est sur le début de quelque
chose c'est vraiment toute nouvelle
révolution qui arrive ça va vraiment
changer la donne au niveau du smartphone
on n'est pas sur un produit qui est
aujourd'hui le plus parfait possible
très clairement par contre je trouve
vraiment bien très bien fini très
intéressant et le fait d'avoir au final
cette petite encoche à côté je trouve
pas ça si dérangeant parce qu'il faut
vraiment l'imaginer en termes d'usagé
c'est-à-dire que votre smartphone
lorsque vous avez regardé par exemple
une vidéo
vous avez effectivement ces petites
parties mais pour jouer un jeu ça pose
absolument aucun problème pour naviguer
sur internet pour aller régler votre
alarme comme l'a par exemple ou faire
tout ce que vous voulez ça disparaît
complètement ça se prendre un paysage et
ça pour que ça fasse pas de problème
typiquement un exemple lorsque vous
mettez comme ça on le voit quasiment pas
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
au niveau de la r&d sur un écran pearl
elle ce n'est pas possible actuellement
de venir vous mettre une petite bulle
alors à l'avenir on sait que les choses
vont évoluer
on est comme je vous lis quelque chose
de tout nouveau qui commencent à arriver
et franchement pour un premier produit
je trouve que samsung a vraiment un truc
est hyper sexy très sympa je me
demandais vraiment ce que ça allait
donner
mais la sensation est ce que vous le
prenez en main mais aussi la sensation
d'avoir un produit robuste un produit
qui est sérieux on n'est pas sur un truc
mort d'ib on oublie ça risque de se
casser on voit effectivement sais pas si
vous le voyez bien au milieu on a là la
marque de la pliure qu'on voit ici bon
lorsque vous naviguez lorsque vous le
touchez sous le doigt on le sent
légèrement mais ça ne pose pas de
problème je trouve vraiment pas ça
dérangeant en plus y'a un truc qui est
intéressant et c'est un boulot de fait
samsung on retrouve notamment sur les
galaxy s 10 la gamme et se disent c'est
le fait d'avoir un écran amoled
dynamique c'est-à-dire qu'il va venir
réduit
la lumière bleue vous l'avez également
sur ce smartphone là c'est vraiment un
enjeu majeur pour les constructeurs
c'est très important pour le
consommateur de réduire les lumières
bleues pour la fatigue oculaire avec lui
toutes les maladies oculaires donc c'est
vraiment un truc qui est hyper hyper
hyper important là dessus c'est pareil
il ya un gros boulot qui est fait de la
part de samsung en plus vous pouvez
venir vous par vous même dans les
réglages de l'appareil réduit à la
lumière bleue donc c'est intéressant il
faut savoir qu'avec cette petite techno
vous avez quand même 40 % de réduction
en termes de lumière bleue autre point
intéressant c'est l'optimisation qui est
faite du point de vue de l' os si vous
avez suivi vous savez que samsung a
aujourd'hui one way pour ses smartphones
c'est exactement la même chose là dessus
vous avez un roi nu mais qui
complètement adapté à ce nouveau format
ce nouveau form factor il tourne sur un
android 9 paille
il ya un vrai gros boulot qui est fait
également en partenariat avec google
notamment pour leur permettre d'avoir
des applications qui vont être
complètement adapté directement à ce
nouveau form factor ça c'est cool ça
vous permet d'avoir notamment des vidéos
sur youtube qui sont complètement
adaptés à ce format là et autre point
qui est très très très important et je
demande où tout à l'heure c'est sur maps
lorsque vous allez chercher votre chemin
de l'avenir vous baladez vous avez
quelque chose qui est complètement
optimisé qui est vraiment très agréable
moi c'est vraiment la sensation que j'ai
en prenant ce produit c'est la première
fois que je le prends aujourd'hui on en
reparlera beaucoup des smartphones
écrans club où ça surtout qui
m'intéresse beaucoup parce que je pense
aussi l'avenir du smartphone s'est fait
d'abord un vrai confort un vrai confort
de visionnage vous êtes beaucoup plus à
l'aise vous avez beaucoup plus accès à
l'information sans tenir vous fatigué et
je trouve ça vraiment génial regardez
pour naviguer je vois où je suis
directement sans galérer un smartphone
qui sera disponible le 3 mai prochain
que vous allez pouvoir retrouver alors
pas partout mais samsung va vraiment
choisir les personnes avec qui travaille
vous n'êtes pas retrouver votre
smartphone de disponibles on est sur un
smartphone exigeant on est sur un
smartphone à plus de 2000 euros c'est
pas un produit qui est tout de suite
hyper accessible
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'on est
quelque chose de tout nouveau c'est une
vraie révolution elle va vouloir la
petite troupe
une vraie révolution c'est sont des
choses qui vont évoluer il ya aussi
huawei et qui a sorti cas présentent en
tous cas sa copie ya pas très
il ya plein d'autres acteurs qui vont
bien sont le marché au bout d'un moment
mécaniquement les tarifs vont baisser
les produits vont devenir encore plus
performant encore plus beau encore plus
optimisée ça c'est vraiment hyper
intéressant produit je vous disais que
sera disponible début mais vous allez
pouvoir retrouver avec une petite
protection en kevlar pour venir le
protéger alors contrairement aux coques
classiques qui sont en un bout là vous
avez votre protection en debout c'est
pas mal ça doit quand même le protégez
vous mettez ça à l'arrière ici comme ça
hop ça s'adapte bien vous mettez l'autre
parti ici à l'avant ça vous protège
votre smartphone si toutefois il prend
un shoot ça c'est top
assez intéressant c'est très design tout
ça sympa en plus comme vous n'avez pas
de prise jack
samsung vous offre une paire de galaxies
bugs vous avez un an d'assurance samsung
capte plus offert pour votre smartphone
en rose a besoin notre joker si vous
avez un problème est bien moins pendant
un an vous c'est que vous êtes
tranquille vous êtes coup là parce que
11 10 avec ces nouvelles techno à quai
ce qui pourrait se passer si j'ai un
problème ça permet je pense de rassurer
le consommateur s'associe bien que ça me
semblait penser comme ça et vous avez
une hotline dédiée vous prenez votre
téléphone
celui là où un autre et vous appelez
vous dites voilà j'ai une question
comment faire ça j'ai un problème tu as
qu'est ce qui se passe en termes
d'entretien qu'est ce que vous me
conseillez et du coup vous avez
quelqu'un de samsung de l'autre côté qui
est là pour vous conseiller pour vous
assister pour vous aider c'est bien en
tout cas pas ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il
ya une vraie volonté de la part de
samsung pour accompagner ce tout nouveau
form factor à nrg rassurer le
consommateur ça c'est plutôt bien et ça
va dans le bon sens en tout cas je le
trouve vraiment bien je suis convaincue
par les usages du produit le produit ne
tente énormément faire une triste et
d'avant pacte pour pouvoir se
rencontrent en situation je dirais bien
lorsque je me balade dans la rue avec
mon maps
le sortir facilement en plus ce qui est
bien c'est que regarder hop il passe
bien dans une poche
alors j'ai du bordel dans un match après
l'autre ils passent bien dans une poche
je pense que c'est exactement la même
chose avec un sac à main ou glisser par
rapport à un autre smartphone il est
bien plus grand il est forcément un peu
plus épais mais c'est pas non plus
hallucinant le fromage bien et il est un
peu moins large
donc en termes de gain de place au final
vous n'êtes pas mal sur ce sur ce type
au logis de produits en produits que je
trouve intéressant qui est prometteur
qui montre l'avenir de la téléphonie
mobile et que je ne peux en tout cas si
vous avez les moyens je vous recommande
pas ce qu'on trouve ça vraiment
intéressant alors on en reparlera
why qu'ainsi on laisse tranquille là
dessus mais moi je trouve vraiment
vraiment intéressant dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez comment vous trouvez
ce format est ce que vous trouvez ça
intéressant est ce que vous pourriez
vous projeter avec ce type de produit
avec un grand écran comme ça est ce que
vous pourriez acheter ce produit est
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du prix qui
est justifiée par rapport aux produits
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter oui/non shalit a marqué tout ça
en bas en commentaire en termes de
couleurs il est dispo en argent comme ça
en noix également ça vous allez
retrouver dans les boutiques partenaires
samsung mais il sera également
disponible dans deux autres couleurs
j'ai tout noter ici sur mon du sèche en
bleu et en vert uniquement sur le shop
de samsung voilà c'est tout pour cette
prise en main de ce produit de ce galaxy
fold merci à samsung d'abord invité pète
parmi les premiers pour découvrir
vous avez bien évidemment me dire tout
ce que vous en pensez en commentaire
puis moi je trouve cool et on en
reparlera très très prochainement aura
bientôt deux ans
[Musique]